victoria's secret
abandons its scantly dress angel saying
they're no longer
culturally relevant activists and
entrepreneurs will be the new faces of
the brand that says
business insider so the lingerie giant
said on wednesday that it was partnering
with a group of inspirational women
including activists and entrepreneurs to
promote a new brand image and shape its
around
these women who include the indian actor
and entrepreneur
priyanka chopra jonas and the pro soccer
player and gender equality activist
meghan rappano will become
will become the face and voice of the
brand victoria secret says in an
interview with new york times victoria
sector ceo martin
waters said the angels were not
culturally relevant in the late 90s and
2000 victoria's secrets runway show had
a powerful
role in the defined sexy most recently
it's been criticized
as outdated thoughts
i won't hear what kai's going to say
about this as well so go ahead
kai is not a lady no i said you first
but i'm going to go to kai as well as a
22 year old seeing how upset he is
look you're selling an image you're
selling a dream
this is an act of desperate fantasy you
are you're selling a fantasy
this is an act by a company whose
finances have pulled up
angels they're a victim of mall traffic
going down
they don't have a viable online it's
very hard to sell this stuff online you
kind of need to be in the store to try
it on
but malls are dying except for your
you're nice and small so this to me this
is an act of desperation
adam is this catastrophic this is this
is a big deal guys this is probably the
biggest story in the world right now
victoria's secrets
is not they're going unsexy here now be
careful with what you say right consider
the goal this is a big deal i mean look
at these lovely ladies right here
kai get ready use your fingertips here
and now type in
megan rapino okay
this is where we're going ladies and
gentlemen we are now
going from the sexiest ladies on earth
to this lady i get it she's an athlete
respect she does some good stuff on the
field i do not want to see her on the
runway
not even a little bit okay she can do
her thing on the field
keep your ass off the runway megan so i
will say that i think priyanka chopra
jonas is pretty damn hot
wow i will say that this is sort of the
unsexification of america
this will mess up i think we might need
some justin timberlake to get infused to
bring sexy back because if they're we're
we're losing the angels for uh
soccer players this is the equivalent of
nike like um
victoria's secret's a pretty powerful
brand they're a sexy brand you know
women want to aspire to be sexy i get it
guys want to
get their women nice outfits for them to
look sexy you know we're bringing sexy
back jt
this is like nike's saying you know what
we're not really going to use lebron
anymore we're not going to use
mj we're not going to use fantastic
athletes anyway out there
where you see that fat guy over there
you see that john candy looking dude
over there
we're gonna bring his ass over and he's
gonna be the new face of nike
let's keep it sexy let's keep it sporty
and let's keep the women
who deserve to be on the runway on the
run who the hell thought this was a good
idea
like honestly the woke the whoa so so
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question so let's just say
let's flip it let's flip it and say
moving forward
calvin klein models are offending yeah
many many
you just said that and moving forward we
need to bring these guys with big
bellies beer bellies oh yeah beer guts
moving forward that's ronaldo you mean
ronaldo yeah
ironically we do have a rodolfo will be
here
we shouldn't be doing that so the
current ceo by the way go pull up to uh
victoria's secret's uh founder look what
he look is
just put victoria's secret and go to
their wikipedia go to the wikipedia
okay go to uh left go to wikipedia
uh papa papa go lower lower lower lower
lower until you find it
should be coming up here type in wiki uh
where the hell is it with computer okay
anyways go find it because you have to
see who the founder is
um we can eventually get to it okay so
look at the founder
uh roy raymond click on roy raymond
that's him
he looks like the founder victoria's
secret yeah okay credit he looks like a
guy
that would come out with something like
that okay
so now here's what i want you to do next
i want you to now
go to the current ceo of victoria's
secret okay go to go to
go to the same uh wikipedia and then
type in that name right there
stuart yeah him right there okay copy
paste
go somewhere this is what he looks like
okay so
you know extremely conservative
he was a former home depot executive
okay
he was a senior vice president of
finance for home depot
he was a senior director at pizza hut
before he was an
auditor and a manager and a cpa at
deloitte for six years so this guy was
an accountant he's a bean counter
the ceo of a brand like freaking
victoria's secret
makes no sense to me it's it's it's as
if playboy's
ceo all of a sudden becomes a former cfo
of uh you know pick a company there you
know
new york times i'm going to go be the
playboy magazine moving forward what
we're going to be doing is it's not fun
to be a bunny because a bunny is
offensive
the animal we're going to use as a
[Laughter]
donkey
instead of we're gonna use this right
and the company that owns victoria's
secrets is a company called
l brands who is el branson that's what
i'm saying l brands is
their finances are in a shambles yeah
well they own a ton of uh retail clothes
yeah
by the way kai was supposed to give his
opinion on victoria's secret let's
let's get kai involved here he's been in
a bad mood the last couple weeks
yeah because they're taking away the sex
what it is uh victoria's secret bunnies
makes a lot of sense
there used to be angels out there and
now there's definitely curious this is
just a
catastrophe it's very very what do you
guys think
what do you guys think are you
david you can't you're going to be
diplomatic here listen um
[Music]
we hear the audio in the background
you're listening to it so you might want
to take them like
yeah vanessa you go it's just by the way
shout out to vanessa was just her
birthday
our extraordinary production what's your
opinion
yeah did you have one or no go ahead
honestly there's like different likes
for everyone
i don't really care you don't really
care david what do you think
i think victoria's secret was that brand
it was that sexy you know that's what it
was
and so now to have it change it's
interesting i think it might be just be
for attention maybe a little bit and
then it'll be gonna go back to the same
yeah like
what was it ihop from ihop international
house of burgers yeah what do you think
jokes
uh so i think it's interesting both of
them should run for office very
difficult yeah i got zero answers
you've got no answers they should coach
some other
where's that where's the no but i think
it was the democrats no that's not the
uh
for me i think what what's interesting
aspect of it is that here it is
they've always been one extreme where
it's been skinnier the skinnier the
better the more
unrealistic looking the better that's
kind of how things have gone
which now to what adam was saying with
the world culture it's kind of bouncing
back
but i think it's going the other
opposite extreme like there's
some uh dove and stuff stuff like that
in terms of their like the bosch soap
and stuff like that
they've landed a little bit more in the
middle where you have some neutral
ground where it's like you're more
it's more realistic it's not as extreme
but you're also not now
going to complete other opposite i don't
see why an entrepreneur in sexy lingerie
is
is the new like the news i gotta tell
you story i gotta tell you story
maybe i've told the story before but i
gotta tell you this so it's so
appropriate right now i'm at i'm at
harvard obm
uh uh what's it the owner president
management program the opm program it's
like three weeks you stay in harvard
right
and one of my classmates is the founder
of this
victoria's secret lingerie company of
new zealand europe and australia
okay and he's killing it billionaires
seven thousand employees
kicking us he's sitting right next to me
and he looks like the guy that would
start a victorious secret ask type of a
company
so at the end of it out of 164 students
eight of us are presenting
our ideas i'm one of them he's one of
them so he comes up and he says
so here's what i need i'm trying to
raise a half a billion dollars
and here's what my products are he shows
the products he says here's this product
here's that product
here's what we said this is our
best-selling product the whole you know
strings going down all the time he just
got some legit stuff
he says but to be and by the way very
monotone guy says but to be honest with
you this doesn't do its service
i think it's important for all you guys
to visually see what all this work looks
like on somebody
can i please have my helpers show up
eight girls walk
up at a heart talking about half naked
yeah
linetto who was running the whole show
she panicked she runs she does market
research here she
runs around takes her jack you guys
can't do this this is gonna be all over
the news
you guys can't do this trying to cover
these girls this is harvard and you see
students are like
we want to see the product
so if you like the product that's why i
need a half a billion invest with me he
went off the stage he ended up winning
just because
he fooled everybody but i tell you
harvard was so
flippin nervous because of this whole
thing like oh my god gosh
god forbid so anyways i don't know what
direction they're going i don't know
what's going to happen
all i know is when you dramatically
change the philosophy
of your business and you dramatically
change your customer like you know
what's rule number one of business no
customer
you officially change your customer when
jerry springer went from his show
jerry springer says i don't want to be
this guy that's going around talking
about fights and people jumping on top
of each other i'm a smart guy i was a
former mayor of cincinnati i have
opinions
i want to be like more oprah winfrey
they went that direction
ratings disappeared catastrophically his
producer says
dude you're not oprah you are jerry
springer
you know he's the daddy he's not the
daddy that's who you are
because they knew their customer these
guys are screwing up not knowing who the
customers i don't know i just don't
think it's smart in a business sense let
me say
from a business perspective we all have
certain principles there's certain you
know truths in business
and number one is sex sells don't be
scared of that sex sells
number two stay in your lane you're the
sexy you're the sexy company or
victoria's secrets
sex sells stay sexy baby don't bring
sexy back keep staying sexy
man yeah last but not least stay sexy
and last but not least the riches are in
the niches so you're in the sexy
niche stay sexy baby that's all i'm
trying to say all right we don't
know one thing we like a good comparison
for this you know how like with food
when they advertise what a burger looks
like
for mcdonald's versus what it really
looks like yeah and you have like hot
wings or whatever
yeah it's kind of like instead of taking
the picture of what it
what their commercials are they should
just take it like uh when you open up a
frozen bag of wings and dump it on the
in in whatever bowl or something they
should just start advertising that so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]